إنها مسألة توقيت التوقيت
مهم ويجب اليوم أن
تكون لدينا حكومة كما ذكرت أه 13
شهرا بدون فراغ حكومي وعلى
مستوى الحكومة
لم يتخذ قرار
الانهيار
والمزيد من الانهيار في القطاع المالي
مزيد من الانهيار في الكل.  قطاعات التعليم
ورؤساء الطاقة لذا حان
الوقت لوجود حكومة
في هذه المرحلة نعم أنا أقوم
بالإصلاحات السريعة التي يجب القيام بها على
الفور خاصة الطاقة أه
التثقيف الصحي أه أه العمل بشفافية
و  يُظهر الحرية للبنانيين أن
هناك حكمًا ، هناك شفافية
وهذا ما نحاول القيام به ،
سأضغط عليك بشأن هذا مع الاحترام
سيدي لماذا يجب أن يثق الشعب اللبناني
بك
وبهذه الحكومة كما أقول وجوهًا جديدة ولكن
هذا هو  حكومة اختارتها نفس
المؤسسة السياسية القديمة
التي سئمها شعب لبنان
بصراحة تامة
في لبنان ، لا يوجد انقلاب
لأناس لا يثقون في أنهم لا يستطيعون
تغييره.  بين عشية وضحاها ، نحن فترة انتقالية
نحو التغيير لأخذ
البلد نحو الانتخابات والسماح
للناس بتحديد من يريدون لاحقًا
على الأقل في هذا الوقت الذي يحتاجون إليه كما
ذكرت في البداية ، إنها
مسألة توقيت يحتاجون إلى شخص ما للتعامل معه.
لا أحب أن أقول إدارة الأزمة
فحسب ، لكن حاول على الأقل إيقاف هذا
السقوط الحر ومحاولة إنقاذ لبنان ، هذا
ما سنفعله بالضبط
أحد أكثر القضايا الاقتصادية إلحاحًا التي يتعين على
حكومتك معالجتها هو
تكلفة البلد  برنامج دعم
الوقود والأدوية ، وكلاهما يعرف
قصورًا شديدًا في لبنان في الوقت
الحالي ، هل
تقترح رفع
هذا الدعم ، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فما هي
خطتك بعد
ذلك ، يكاد يكون الدعم على وشك الرفع
لأننا لا نملك ما ذكرته
ليس لدينا أي
نقود أو احتياطي ندفعه لدفع
دعم
النفط أو جميع السلع
الأخرى ، سنحتفظ بدعم
الأدوية وخاصة الأدوية المزمنة
ولكن س  لقد تم رفعه تقريبًا
ونحن في طريقنا للاحتفاظ به للحفاظ على
الاستيراد المجاني لجميع هذه
المجتمعات وهذا ما نخطط للقيام به
لأنه في الحقيقة ليس لدينا المال
، من الواضح جدًا أنك فقط أعطيك
مثال آخر مرة في الأشهر القليلة الماضية
من العام ، وأكثر
ما ننفقه لدعم السلع بما
يزيد عن 10 مليارات ، وهو أكثر بكثير من
10 مليارات ، اكتشفنا أن 26
بالمائة من الدعم
يستخدمه والمستخدم النهائي اللبناني و 75 و
74 تم إساءة استخدامها من قبل التجار من قبل
الأشخاص الفاسدين وهذا
ما سنقوم أيضًا بالتحقيق فيه حول مكان وجود هذه
الأموال حيث تم القيام بهذه الأموال ، لذلك من
المهم جدًا إيقاف
الدعم والبدء في بناء لبنان
في الداخل فيما بعد.  من خلال
مفاوضات جيدة للغاية مع
البنك الدولي IAF وجميع الأصدقاء
والمجتمع الدولي ، ينتمي اثنان من الوزراء الـ 24
المختارين في
حكومتك إلى حزب الله ،
وقد دعم حزب الله رئاستك للوزراء علنًا ، هل تدعم
سأقول لك بصراحة إنني
عملي للغاية وأرى ما يهمني
هو أنني أهتم بلبنان
كيف يمكنني إنقاذ
لبنان لدي وزيرين نعم ، إنهما
صديقان لحزب الله وحزب الله
كحزب سياسي موجود في لبنان لذا
لا يمكنني تجاوز
هذا المجتمع ، لا يمكنني
تجاوز هذا الحزب وهم
يقولون إن لدي شخصان متخصصان
يمكنني التعامل مع
هدفي اليوم ، فأنا أقول من
فضلك ضع جانبًا سياسيًا ودعنا نرى
كيف يمكننا إنقاذ هذا البلد
كان من المقرر إنقاذ هذا البلد ، فلدينا
أشخاص طيبون ولدينا موارد جيدة
ويمكننا حفظها ، لذلك إذا أردنا أن نبدأ
في البقاء هذا واحدًا من هذا الطرف
والآخر من الطرف الآخر فلن
ننقذ هذا البلد أبدًا.
أجبرت على أخذ هذين
العضوين
، هل أجبرت على أخذهما إلى
خزانتك ،
آسف ، هل أجبرت على أخذ
هؤلاء ، أنا مجبر
لا لا لا ، لست لأني
لست مجبرًا على الإطلاق  أنا لست
مجبرًا على الإطلاق على أخذهم  إنه
قراري أن أتخذه لنقول ما
إذا كنا سنحصل اليوم غدًا
على نتيجة من IMF ، فيجب أن تمر
عبر مجلس الوزراء ، أود أن
يكون القرار والقرار التالي مجهول الهوية
بشأن تنفيذ
هذا إذا لم يكونوا هناك ،
فلن يتم تنفيذه ، ولهذا
السبب أود أن يطلعني الجميع على
هذا النوع من القرارات ،
وصلت أولى القوافل الرابحة التي تحمل
وقودًا إيرانيًا إلى لبنان من
سوريا بالأمس فقط.  دورة
بتيسير من حزب الله هل ترحب
بهذا الدعم
أه في الحقيقة أقول لك بصراحة أنا حزين
أنا حزين لأن هذا نقص
في سيادة لبنان
لسيادة لبنان أه أفضل
عدم الإدلاء بأي تعليق آخر
لأننا نحاول  لحل هذه المشكلة
بطريقة هادئة للغاية ولكن هذه الشحنة كما
تعلمون تنتهك عقوباتنا ، هل أنت
قلق من أن لبنان سيواجه عقابًا
من قبلنا
من خلال العقوبات على سبيل المثال
منذ الخطيئة  CE
لم توافق حكومة إيبانيز على هذه الحكومة اللبنانية ،
لا ، لم ألعب شيئًا ولم يتقدم أحد
للحصول على هذا ، نحن
لا نتعامل في هذا مطلقًا ، لذا لا
أصدق أه الحكومة اللبنانية ستكون
خاضعة لأي أه
يمكن فرض العقوبات على هذا النحو ، لكن لكني
لا أعرف نوع الإجراءات
التي سيتخذونها للأشخاص الذين يستخدمون
هذا الزيت ، فإن هذا النوع من زيت الوقود له
وقود صعودي يصل قبل
أن تتمكن حكومتك من تسليم شحنة
متفق عليها مسبقًا مع العراق  يبدو
سيئًا جدًا ، أليس كذلك ،
لقد وصلت اليوم ، إنها شحنة من
العراق وصلت اليوم ونرحب بهذا
،
وهنا أغتنم الفرصة مرة أخرى
لأشكر قوات الحكومة العراقية ،
حزب الله هو ذراع إيران داخل لبنان ،
فهي قوية
ومؤثرة ولكن مع  نموهم
هم أيضًا
دعونا نكون صريحين يعيقون قدرة لبنان
على إعادة التواصل
مع الحلفاء الإقليميين والعالميين ،
لذا أسألك سيدي ، هل هناك خطة
لممارسة السيطرة
على حزب
الله ، كما ذكرت ، إنها
سياسة  الحزب في لبنان موجود
ولكن الأهم ألا يكون
لبنان منصة لأي مؤامرة
ضد أي بلد آخر خارج أه
خارج لبنان هذا هو الأهم
بالنسبة لي هذا ما يمكنني أن أعده
بإمكاني أن أفعله
للأسف ، ماذا يمكنني أن أتبع
ما تقصده بذلك من الخارج
ولا أسمح لهم بفعل
ما تعلمون أن الكلمة العربية
اليوم تتخذ هذا الموقف
لأنهم يعتقدون أن حزب الله
يقول من لبنان إنهم يصنعون
دعنا نقول لوسائل
الإعلام التدريب أه الأشياء التي تم القيام بها في لبنان
لهذا السبب يعتقدون أنه ليس لدي أي
دليل ولكني سأبذل قصارى جهدي
لتغيير صورة لبنان هذه
، لقد قلت إن لبنان يحتاج
إلى العالم العربي ، دعنا فقط  ابدأ من هناك
حول المكان الذي يحتاج فيه لبنان إلى المساعدة في هذه
المرحلة ، كيف يمكنك على سبيل المثال وصف
علاقة لبنان أه مع حلفائه في لعبة الجولف
مثل المملكة العربية السعودية والإمارات العربية المتحدة
على سبيل المثال الذين توترت علاقاتهم مع لبنان
على مر السنين بسبب
تأثير حزب الله ،
لبنان هو مؤسس
الجامعة العربية ،
نحن دائمًا
خلال العقود الماضية
في علاقة جيدة جدًا مع
العالم العربي اليوم.  يا أخي لكل
الدول العربية أن تأتي وتتحمل
يدنا وتأخذ لبنان من هذه الفوضى
هذا ما دعوتي
للعالم العربي وما سبب
العيش من الامتحانات الليبرالية الأجنبية المهمة جدا
آسف ما هو الرد
آسف ما هو الرد  كان رد
هؤلاء الإخوة الكبار على سبيل المثال المملكة
العربية السعودية حتى الآن
حتى الآن خلال الأيام الأربعة الماضية
وسبعة أيام ، ولم يكن لدي أي رد
لا سلبيًا أو إيجابيًا ، لكنني
متأكد من أنني متأكد من أنه سيكون في الأيام المقبلة
استجابة إيجابية
لأنهم سيرون مدى
جدية سنفعل وكيف نعمل
، ومن مصلحة جميع العرب في
كل المنطقة والعالم العربي أن يكون لبنان مستقرًا.